okay come on come on come on hold up i'm
gonna worry about you
dime
don't miss oh my god brad are you
serious
i take the game everywhere i'd go
doesn't matter where nine times out of
ten my players feel nothing like me he's
taller he's stronger faster so i'm able
to try things that i wish i could do in
real life you got to make sure you're
close shot and driving dunk driving lit
make sure that's up because you know
without that you don't have much take
the midi out we need the mini for the
city my defense is terrible i gotta pick
that up it was this easy everybody would
do it you know if i could be able to
just pick and choose
it would be too bad i'm gonna make sure
i have a consistent jumper you got a guy
on our team rudy gaye whose jump shot
has always been elite there he is there
we go struggle pull-ups capital rent
stuff i just don't want to be trash
[Music]
being able to shoot a bike or a
skateboard i think is one of the cool
parts with this 2k which i think is
pretty dope makes you feel like you're
riding around doing your thing like
you're back in the day as a kid
now we're gonna head to adidas store
we're trying to find some stuff to wear
and while i'm out there hooping i'm
gonna go ahead and obviously pick my
shoe we got the ones the retros that's
what i call them uh
you know i think being able to have my
shoe here the game where i can customize
i think is pretty is pretty dope you
play against other people and they're
wearing your stuff
i think to me it's one of the coolest
things ever i'm kind of dabbling into
fashion but i would never do a fashion
walk in real life i feel like the runway
is like you know you're all the way
there
hesitant freestyle let's see what we got
here
okay you know yeah you know something's
quick and light and then just showing
off the the twos
uh the other retros how the retro downs
it's crazy seeing brick in the game i've
known him since i was in college he was
able to kind of put me through some
drills and teach him some different
things to see him in the game basically
doing the stuff we do back home is
pretty dope in the gym low-key looks
like bricks except it's a full court
which i think is pretty cool it's kind
of like real life in order to be one of
the greats you have to continue to go
back into the gym
the bots play amazing defense you should
definitely play against director of
people
good defense that's the best of all
let me just win the game real quick
roll roll
camera thank you you have a new season i
think something that's pretty dope
because it keeps things fresh and i
think the different quest inspires
people to continue to get better at
their player i would definitely try out
the music mogul quest i've always loved
music i love the process behind music
hopefully become one of the greats
the game brings people together our
plane got delayed in indiana for like
two hours and i happen to have my game
on the bus and i brought it in the
locker room until it was like one of
those things where it's like it just
worked out we all started playing
against each other i think that was
something that was pretty cool you see
me on tv but you know we do the same
thing like i'm out here playing the game
with you guys i think that's one of the
best things about the nba the way we
engage with fans and i think 2k does a
great job of allowing us to do that as
well
i didn't like that hook shot no no way
oh that's a bad shot i didn't even do
that oh my god brad are you serious oh
yeah oh yeah oh
oh there it is
and what shopping shopping again
can i get a foul dime
don't miss it
no no no come on bro we got chemistry
issues on this team over here
[Music]
i gotta get back in the gym this is
terrible